quand j'aurai bienvenue pour ce stop
science nous allons tenter de répondre à
la merde tous les mystères à la plus
grande question tous les temps les
tortues sont elles des dinosaures en
voilà une question qu'elle est bonne
parce que si on en croit la presse les
actualités récentes et semblerait que
oui et il faut bien dire que c'est bon
gros reptile qu'est le lien ont tous du
dinosaure qui n'a jamais entendu dire tu
es tortues étaient des reliques d'un
autre âge alors essayons d'y voir un peu
plus clair là dedans déjà commençons par
identifier l'objet de nos préoccupations
les tortues c'est super d'être à
carapace c'est certain que n'importe qui
est capable d'identifier une tortue au
premier coup d'oeil la carapace et à la
tortue ce que les incisives sont aux
rongeurs
à de rares exceptions près comme les
tortues molle trio liquider les tortues
ont une carapace dure bien pratique pour
les paléontologues cal se fossilise très
facilement pour hind en fossiles de
mammifères découverte et les
paléontologues découvre plusieurs kilos
de carapaces de tortues elles sont pour
cela très utile lors de la recherche de
fossiles car les tortues vivent surtout
en eau douce c'est à dire là où les
probabilités de fossilisation de
dinosaures ou de mammifères sont les
plus grandes
tous vers une tortue c'est toujours bon
signe parlant leur carapace justement la
carapace des tortues n'est pas une sorte
de coque dont les tortues peuvent se
débarrasser n'importe quand non elle
fait partie intégrante de leur squelette
un squelette l extérieur vous devez
avoir du mal à croire ça mais c'est bien
calés tortues ont réalisé le vieux
fantasme de l'exosquelette c'est très
simple la carapace de tortue c'est quoi
juste de résultat de la fusion
d'éléments du squelette avec des hausses
ification de la peau transformer comme
dans le cuir de croco ainsi en regardant
à la der de la cara base une tortue vous
découvrirez que les côtés les vertèbres
de la colonne vertébrale sont toutes
fusionner entre elles
ça se voit très bien sur les embryons et
que le tout est fusionnée à l'extérieur
avec de la peau aussi fier le ventre
quant à lui qu'on appelle le plastron
est composé de côtes ventrale et du
sternum et les épaules vous avez vu où
elles sont les épaules
elles sont à l'intérieur des côtes au
lieu d'être à l'extérieur c'est pas
d'âme ça ben en même temps comment dieu
qu'elle rentre la tête et les bras si
les épaules sont collés à l'extérieur
bref pour vous la faire courte la
carapace de tortue ce sont les eaux de
la cage thoracique et de l'europe
domaine tous fusionner et quand on y
arrive
si bien si la cage thoracique des
tortues à évoluer en carapace et ainsi
que quelque part dans le passé il y à
300 millions d'années a tué existait une
tortue avec un thorax non modifiés une
tortue avec les épaules obama et sans
carapace
pouvez vous imaginer cela une seconde ce
sera un peu comme un éléphant centre on
abat tiens c'est un bon exemple ça quand
on remonte assez loin dans le temps on
en trouve des éléphants faucille et le
peuple gros caronna et qui ne porte pas
de tron et il ne vivait qu'il ya 50
millions d'années maintenant il faut
vous imaginer que les tortues sont
apparus il n'y a pas 50
il n'y a pas cent ni encore moins 200
médias au moins 300 millions d'années
ces 50 millions d'années avant les
premiers leaders imaginez seulement à
quoi les tortues pouvait bien ressembler
lcd buggy bon d'accord on va vous aider
à voie similaire tard un fossile
sud-africain vieux de 250 millions
d'années c'est pas les plus anciens
parmi les tortues mais c'est en tout cas
celui qui ressemble le plus à ce que
l'ancêtre commun des tortues devait être
en gros un look de lézards avec des
côtes légèrement élargie annonçant la
carapace des futurs tortueux mais cette
tendance à l'élargissement des côtes est
bien plus prononcée chez un autre
fossile sud africain la plus ancienne
des tortues connu eux note aux eaux
russes anna taurus et ceci de
particulier qu'ils datent de 260 à 265
millions d'années environ
et donc plus vieux que miller et à ça
peut paraître étrange voire paradoxal
mais il suffit de vous dire qu'en fait
milla était un peu nos deux aux russes
ce que l'ornithorynque est aux
mammifères aujourd'hui pour son époque
et c'était aussi facile à vivre
bon le dernier représentant d'une
branche et audi végétaux dans l'ombre
évolutif de tortue selma comme ça c'est
mieux oui chez eux note aux russes la
partie thoraco abdominale est fortement
différencié du reste du corps et les
côtes très élargie convergent vers
l'extérieur où elle fusionne
partiellement bref et notorious a déjà
le profil d'une tortue ou en tout cas
une belle amorce
c'est d'autant plus vrai que note aux
russes possédaient aussi des tubercules
sur la tête
sorte de véritables qui vaut pour
l'insertion des comptes qui
caractérisait
premières tortues bien qu'on l'ait
représente occasionnellement comme des
êtres aquatique ou semi aquatique une
auto russe et mila était plus
vraisemblablement de tout-petits
herbivore terrestre mais ça va changer
au trias il y à 210 millions d'années
fini les ébauches de tortue cette fois
c'est du lourd c'est du massif des
vertébrés des côtes totalement fusionnée
auxquels s'ajoutent des ossification
dermique et des épines formé par ces
écailles ossifié une tête massive et
cornu une queue en masse darmon pointes
acérées retrouver dans des gisements
partout à travers le monde
elle représente le premier véritable
grand succès d être à carapace il s'agit
des deux n'ont pas de bowser non non il
s'agit de prog anouk ellis plus de 150
millions d'années avant les dinosaures
elle a littéralement inventé la
stratégie de la forteresse vivante
mais attention sa carapace est une vraie
carapace est tortueux principalement
n'ose pas une armure fait de uniquement
de la peau est si fier comme chez les
dinos prog anouk et dix comme les
tortues d'aujourd'hui avait une carapace
complète ses épaules se trouvant déjà à
l'intérieur
aulas de ce moment elles sont pas
téléporter tout de même à non elles ont
tout simplement fait le tour par devant
c'est en tout cas ce que montre une
autre tortue du trias hottentot kelis
très reconnaissable à son surprenant
plastron épineux ainsi que nos 12 aux
russes même si ses épaules était déjà à
l'intérieur de la carapace ce n'est pas
pour autant que progrès de kelis avait
une tête rétractable la tête rétractable
est néanmoins déjà présente chez les
tortues contemporaine comme pro terreau
kheris mais cette caractéristique est
apparu et a disparu plusieurs fois dans
l'évolution des tortues preuve en est
qu'aujourd'hui il a pris part des
tortures entre leur tête verticalement
dans leur carapace alors tu es certaines
tortues de l'hémisphère sud
autrefois très abondante mais plutôt
rare aujourd'hui contre leur tête en
leur carapace horizontalement
cela donne certes le même résultat mais
au niveau du squelette sauna applique
une histoire évolutive très différentes
et le plus marrant ce sont les tortues
marines dont la morphologie des
vertèbres indique qu'elles sont
descendantes des tortues à tête
rétractable verticalement lait qui ne
peut plus rétracter leur tête
en gros vous l'aurez compris les tortues
anbar couru un long chemin évolutive
et leur histoire n'est pas aussi simple
que l'expression reliques de l'ère des
dinosaures le laisse entendre
et si tu apparu et se sont diversifiées
avant les dinosaures rencontrant des le
trias à un grand succès évolutif très
tôt durant leur évolution les tortues
ont dû faire face à un problème de
taille comment respirer quand votre
thorax est totalement immobile et que
vous ne pouvez même pas écarter les
côtes les points les serpents vous le
diront et rescue laissant faire bouger
ses côtes c'est dur et dans lequel est
tortueux c'est d'autant plus dur que
toute la cage thoracique est verrouillée
de l'intérieur
alors comment font-elles chez les
amphibiens ainsi que beaucoup de lézards
et de serpents la respiration est
assurée par des mouvements des muscles
situés entre les côtes
les crocodiles en deux adopter un
système de piston ressemblant beaucoup
au diaphragme des mammifères dans tous
les cas ces systèmes sont des méthodes
d'oxygénation peu efficace carrière
colonne d'air inspiré ne passe pas
complètement dans les poumons
il y a toujours un peu d'air qui reste
dans la trachée et qui ne sert donc à
rien les oiseaux ainsi que le warrant
des savanes et l'iguane baer se sont vus
évoluer une méthode d'oxygénation plus
efficaces ou l'air passe à travers
différents sacs pulmonaire dans une
seule direction
dans cette situation les respirer passe
dans un premier sac puis dans un second
et ressort comme ça mais flux d'air
entrant et sortant ne se croise pas et
100% de l'air inspiré sert à oxygéner le
corps pratique la façon dont les tortues
respire est longtemps restée un mystère
rendez vous compte avant 2007 on n'avait
aucune idée de comment elle faisait on
imaginer qu elle se servait des
contractions des muscles de leurs pattes
pour écraser et 10 date et l'heure tout
mou rendant à ces leur respiration
fortement dépendantes de leurs
déplacements
ouais du coup peut pas dire que ce soit
le pied quoi mais les études récentes
ont montré que c'était faux en vérité
leur façon de respirer ressemble à celle
des crocodiles et des mammifères car les
tortues se servent de leurs muscles
abdominaux comme d'un piston pour ce
qu'on en sait aujourd'hui grâce à une
étude publiée cette année c'est la
contraction des muscles abdominaux qui
compense la fixité des côtes pour la
dilatation des pauvres leur permettant
d'y inscrire
certaines tortues aquatiques en
particulier la tortue australienne de la
fitzroy river utiliserait un autre
système basé sur un piston richement
vascularisé qui servirait
faire aller et venir l'eau non pas dans
les poumons mais dans l'orifice cloaque
al elle respire avec son rectum c'est
sympa non c'est surtout amusant de voir
comment la série surnaturelle a fini par
permettre l'existence simultanée de ces
deux systèmes d'antagonistes en
conclusion les tortues sont elles des
reliques de l'ère des dinosaures la
réponse est non considérer les tortues
comme des fossiles et vivant ça y est
j'ai le droit de le dire oui oui c'est
bon à considérer les tortues comme des
fossiles vivants c'est négliger leurs
300 millions d'années d'évolution qui
ont donné naissance à plusieurs milliers
d'espèces fossiles et à plus de 300
espèces vivant c'est à dire autant que
de primates
faisons un parallèle simple avec
l'évolution des armes de jet ya d'abord
eu les projectiles comme le javelot puis
des inventions et dans le bras de
l'homme dans la propulsion du projectile
le propulseur puis le projectile s'est
réduit et a été projeté par un arc puis
par une arbalète diaboliquement
puissante et enfin sont apparus les
armes à feu vous savez tous d'accord
pour dire que comme pour les tortues
l'ère des accès des flèches est
aujourd'hui définitivement révolu et
nous sommes bel et bien entré
aujourd'hui dans l'ère des armes à feu
diriez vous pour autant que les hommes
modernes sont des reliques du passé non
je ne crois pas ils ont continué
d'évoluer et les tortues c'est pareil
c'est pas parce qu'elle présente un plan
d'organisation anciens qu'aucune
évolution n'a été possible autour de ce
plan bases éthiques
alors si ce ne sont pas les dinosaures
que sont les tortues on a d'abord cru
qu'avec leurs crânes lourd massif est
dépourvu d'ouverture autre que leur [ __ ]
comme peuvent en avoir les crocodiles ou
le speno dont calais tortue appartenait
un pseudo groupe de reptiles très
anciens les ânes abside dont font aussi
partie les célèbres pareil à sorrus
escutes aux russes pourquoi un seul euro
et bien tout simplement parce que
l'absence d'ouverture sur le crâne est
un caractère primitif dit simplement les
amphibiens et les poissons non plus
n'ont pas de fausses dans le crâne qui
soit comparable à celle des crocodiles
c'est pas pour autant que les tortues
font partie de la famille des poissons
on ne classe pas les êtres vivants avec
des caractères primitif en l'occurrence
il
génétiques menées très récemment et
basée sur de très nombreuses séquences d
adn ont toutes plus ou moins convergé
vers le même résultat
les tortues serait 2 proche cousine du
groupe d arc aux orres faisant des
tortues de plus proches parents des
crocodiles des oiseaux et des dinos que
du groupe des lézards en gros il y a
plus de lien de parenté entre ça et ça
contre ça et ça ça veut dire que les
tortues avait des ouvertures dans la
tête comme les crocos mais qu'elles les
ont perdu un peu comme les oiseaux où le
monstre de gila on ne le dira jamais
assez mais les tortues ont tellement
évolué depuis leurs débuts qu'en fait il
n'y a plus grand chose dans leur
anatomie qui rendent encore compte de ce
lointain lien de parenté que les crocos
et des oiseaux à part peut-être
l'existence d'un os unique en son genre
le latéraux ce fait nos idées qui ferme
la boîte crânienne et les crocs que les
oiseaux et les tortues se distingue
aussi des lézards et des serpents car ce
sont les seuls êtres écailleux à
posséder des organes génitaux un père
talent don de rendre ça d'un ennuyeux
c'est affligeant
bon voilà les crocos et les audio ils
ont 15 asie alors que les serpents et
les lézards qu'ils en ont deux tu es
satisfait comme ça rabat joueur a l'air
pour l'instant toutes les tortues
fossiles qui ont été découvertes et dont
nous avons parlé on t'a crâne massif
sans ouverture à l'intérieur
mais si l'hypothèse d'une origine
commune avec les oiseaux et les crocos
et bret adore il reste encore à
découvrir le précieux crack de tortues
qui sera percée de petits trous c'est
stop c'est terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi on vous laisse plein de lien pour
en savoir plus dans la description
merci à tous